pub
[Musique]
elle se venge pas des hommes en général
c'est une femme qui cherche sa liberté
qui veut qu'il veut qui veut
qui qui essaye de rester libres dont qui
essayent de s'affranchir de
d'où des hommes en tout cas de ceux qui
lui propose de l'argent pour
voilà pour la tenir pour avoir de
l'ascendant sur elle
et puis parce que si on est dans une
époque qui n'est pas la nôtre
même si aujourd'hui ça résonne quand
même très très fort et puis et puis elle
va essayer donc de s'affranchir de de ce
joug masculin sans être spécialement
méchante d'ailleurs avec les hommes qui
sont dans son auberge elle elle refuse
juste voilà ce petit ascendant qu'on
pourrait avoir sur elle de dire je vais
vous protéger je vais vous offrir des
cadeaux je vais lâcher dit ok mais c'est
pour ça vous fait plaisir mais moi j'en
ai pas besoin
et puis il va arriver un homme assez
méprisant et dense est dans cette
auberge qui va me qui ne va pas
considérer son travail ce que pour elle
elle fait partie de la bourgeoisie que
défend beaucoup golden i sade
bourgeoisie montante qui travaillent les
gens qui travaillent qui s'en sortent
par le travail elle représente beaucoup
ça et
et la liberté que ça implique aussi et
donc ce chevalier va venir mettre un
coup de pied dans sa petite fourmilière
parce qu'il va lui lui reprocher ça il
va lui reprocher son travail et la façon
dont elle se comporte donc elle va
essayer de se venger de ceux de cet
homme là mais va s'ouvrir une brèche
dans cette histoire qu'a l'air tout bien
bien ficelé c'est à dire que l a jamais
et jamais tomber amoureuse elle a jamais
connu l'amour et lui non plus et en fait
ils vont se rendre compte qu'ils sont
pareils qui est défendre leur liberté
tous les deux et
de manière totalement différente mais
ils défendent leur liberté tous les deux
ils vont se rendre compte qu'ils sont
très proches finalement donc est-ce
qu'elle va perdre sa liberté à cause de
cet homme c'est elle c'est le sujet de
la pièce
pour moi la france un grand m
c'est un grand maître pour moi parce que
ça a été cette voie là c'est quelqu'un
qui savait 20 ans par comme ça voilà
temps en temps je travaille avec alain
tout et tout est précis c'est pas rien
rien n'est choisi au hasard aucune place
n'était hasard aucun geste n'est
hasardeuse aucun canton bois c'est
toujours au même moment parce que c'est
raconte quelque chose c'est pas parce
que s'est fixés c'est pas c'est pas une
miss c'est pas une mise en scène figée
mais c'est mémé tous racontent quelque
chose et que la façon dont on se tient
dont on croit ces gens dont on prend un
verre à quel moment en bois quel moment
on se retourne
ou est-ce qu'on est placé dans le plan
dans le cadre par rapport aux autres
tout ça raconte quelque chose pour lui
ouais il est diabolique scrupuleux et
méticuleux mais c'est pour ça qu'on les
aime
je t'aime beaucoup j'aime beaucoup parce
qu'on sent on se lasse pas je crois
enfin pour ma part en tout cas je me
lasse pas de travailler avec ces gens là
qui sont des gens tellement de grand
talent de laurent stocker de le voir en
hitler et puis là avec son tablier
ou en vanilla avec sa petite chemise à
carreaux du colombier à la fois c'est le
même laurent que j'adore avec j'adore
travailler et qui n'est pas du tout le
même et on n'a pas du tout les mêmes
rapports en plus en scène
[Musique]